ah c'est moi je m'appelle johan terraza
je suis photographe et réalisateur est
l'endroit où je suis à ce moment là je
suis entourée de forêts de conifères je
suis entourée de grand séquoia
or moi il ya
montagne qui en est géant roux
d'ailleurs je mets mon souvenir il me
semble que c'est un volcan c'est aussi
fascinant que qu'effrayant
sol est en train de se coucher la brune
qui ressort du des forêts qui éclairé en
rouge
aucune trace humaine tout autour de moi
sur le papier tout ça pour moi c'est du
pain bénit c'est génial parce que
c'est ce que je recherche
nature sauvage dans laquelle je peux
fermez photo explorer je trouvais tout
un tas de choses qui
permettent de m'accomplir
pourtant
à ce moment là je vais pas bien du tout
vraiment pas dans le sac que je porte
non j'ai pas besoin ya un petit peu de
colère mais finalement
tant que ça et pas mal de pleurs
à
surtout beaucoup de tristesse
mon sac il est très mal ajustées geslin
poitrine qui est serré
j'ai mal aux hanches suis fatigué
bref je suis un petit peu en mode survie
mental j'essaie de me raccrocher à tout
ce qu'il ya autour de moi tout ce qui
pourrait me permettre de continuer à
créer resté au présent
là ça fait longtemps et j'en peux plus
j'arrivais un petit peu en bout de
course
et pour que vous compreniez bien
pourquoi et surtout comment j'en suis
arrivée là faut que je revienne quelques
années en arrière
vienne
en 2018
à explorer une vallée perdue des
pyrénées espagnoles avec un ami on part
là bas parce que c'est un coin que je
connais déjà
et qui
est une zone blanche c'est à dire qu'il
n'ya aucun résout même pas sur les
sommets même pas sur les crêtes
autrement dit si vous arrive quelque
chose c'est pour votre pomme
mais nous on pense pas à ça on pense à
explorer ce qu'on la quitte
magnifique qui est réellement superbe
qui est sauvage croisera plein d'animaux
de jour comme de nuit on devra faire
face à des des orages violents tellement
violent que on n'arrive pas à s'entendre
parler sous la grêle le tonnerre alors
que nos tentes sont à 1 mètres l'une de
l'autre
on va être face à des forteresses de
pierre qui sont là depuis des millions
d'années qui sont impressionnantes et
qui se pare de brume tous les soirs
c'est exceptionnel c'est magnifique et
c'est comme pour nous entre guillemets
on va trouver une grotte qu'on va
explorer
or des nuits
[Musique]
vers des toiles
on va avoir des forêts luxuriantes qu'on
va pouvoir
traverser
que vous voulez voir le coin
ces vendeurs
alors on filme tout ça
est
on décide de faire un film sur nos
aventures en tout cas on n'a pas
vraiment de schémas et on se dit qu'on
va filmer ça parce que pour nous c'est
aussi un outil de communication et ça
pourrait me servir professionnellement
et on continue à passer quelques jours
aussi à faire la moue feu de camp et
comme vous pouvez le voir on est
toujours dans des les ambiances qui sont
qui en tout cas nous nous correspondait
nous inspire énormément
puis
passer quelque chose c'est que une fois
rentré chez moi je vais mettre tout ça
sur mon disque dur j'ai des dizaines de
giga d'image des heures et des heures de
photos
et je regarde tout ça
les prises de sons qu'on a fait on a
fait aussi des prises de sons d'ambiance
c'est pas qu'on veut faire
j'ai pas de plomb j'ai rien
du 10 mai
qu est ce qu est ce que je vais faire
comment je vais monter ça qu'est ce que
je vais bien pouvoir raconter de plus
qu'un simple film d' aventure
c'est rien à ce moment là en tout cas
j'en sais rien
la vie reprend son cours
et je suis comprendre une nouvelle
expédition vos voyages si on peut dire
sauf que je suis là je n'ai pas vu venir
j'étais pas préparés et ce voyage vous
le connaissez tous s'appelle une rupture
et à ce moment là il ya un petit peu
tous qui s'écroule autour de moi futur
mon présent l'idée que je pouvais me
faire dans un confort bien établie dans
ma tête
ce à quoi allait ressembler mais
peut-être mes prochaines années mais
prochains mois bref j'étais me
semble-t-il à l'aise à ma place
tout d'un coup
effondre je trouve plus du coup
l'inspiration de travailler et surtout
sans crier gare je me retrouve avec un
sac sur le dos ça que j'ai pas choisi de
porter dans ce sac il ya ce que je vous
ai décrit tout à l'heure il ya beaucoup
de tristesse et de la du stress il ya de
la peur et la poitrine est serré là je
le sais pas encore mais ce sac
diva me
racheter sur le dos pendant un petit
moment et je saurai pas m'en débarrasser
que j'ai je suis obligé d'user de
certains stratagèmes pour 1
à dormir c'est à dire que
j'ai peur de m'endormir parce que j'ai
peur de rêver clairement pas rêver des
bonnes choses
obligé de mettre un petit peu ma vie
entre parenthèses
le travail
le sport
pour finalement être un petit peu en est
à 2
d'habitude les du
c'est comme ça coince et sur sur une
chaise pendant un petit moment
parce qu'il faut aussi se relever qu'il
faut avancer
je tente de faire ça dans tous les cas
il faut que j'aille bosser je pars
travailler dans l'orégon pour un client
aux états unis
et ce travail les super parce que je
vais avoir le temps pour moi de faire
plein de choses de partir dans le
sauvage de films et de faire des photos
bref de produire quelque chose quelque
chose qui me rend vivant et ça tombe
bien parce que ça fait un moment que je
me sens pas vivant j'ai l'impression
d'être sur une boule de stress en fait
appel
bernès
le wilderness rapidement pour ceux qui
savent pas dans les états unis ce sont
ces zones qui sont livrées à elles-mêmes
des zones de nature où l'homme
n'intervient pas très peu et il faut
aussi là bas vous attendre à devoir
payer un petit peu le prix des fois des
rencontres que vous pouvez faire puisque
la faune sauvage aux états unis c'est
pas celle qu'on a ici
et ce territoire qui est
c'est fantastique fabuleux
trouve
sans encore une fois horriblement
stressé même ça ça n'arrive pas à
m'extirper
sans laquelle je suis et puis je vais
tomber sur ce panneau
alors pour ceux qui
comprendrait pas ce qui a marqué c'est
que je suis sur le territoire de l'ours
est évidemment ça sous-entend qu'il faut
être très prudent
c'est marquer il faut plutôt se déplacer
deux jours en groupe faire du bruit pour
se signaler
et ben moi je vais faire exactement
l'inversé je suis seul pas forcément
très bruyant et je compte faire des
photos la nuit
déjà se remplit pas vraiment les quinze
ya pas de raison non plus si les manches
abonnés à ça
mais j'ai besoin de faire ça j'ai besoin
de faire ça en fait pour deux raisons la
première c'est parce que j'ai besoin de
me sentir vivant et en prenant ce risque
là
je me sens vivre ça me fait un petit pas
oublier la situation dans laquelle je
suis
alors je vais partir dans les fourrés
la nuit surtout le soir et
je vais commencer à faire photo il ya un
silence
hier
en
il y a
ces grands arbres qui sont là la nuit
qui est en train de tomber
je commence à explorer la forêt
ça faire des photos je me focus vraiment
sûr maintenant ici au maximum
i
je craque un peu sera qu'un peu je
commence à
à taper un petit peu dans
comment ça a même hurlé avant cassé les
cordes vocales
un sorte
et eux
ça travailler mes images à faire ce
pourquoi je suis là
et
en fait que la nuit véritablement tomber
quoi
et à un moment donné
j'entends
du groupe à
- ils sont 450 mètres chose comme ça
- de ma lampe vers le bruit j'entends se
voit rien parce qu'il est une barre de
buissons et je suis vraiment
plus profond de la forêt je sais pas
trop d'ailleurs à ce moment là où est ma
voiture
ça et je sais par expérience que ce qui
marche c'est gros c'est lourd
je suis au frier que content de ce qui
m'arrive parce qu'en fait à ce moment-là
je suis tellement en détresse que j'ai
besoin qu'on fasse attention à moi et
j'ai pas trouvé le meilleur moyen que de
mettre en danger pour susciter l'intérêt
des gens pour susciter une espèce
d'amour les autres que je n'ai plus
c'est assez paradoxal parce que les
enjeux suite personne au monde en fait
si je suis finalement
moyen de train d'être rejoints syrien
besoin de ça j'ai besoin en fait quelque
part de mettre en danger pour qu'on
fasse attention
est-ce que je les ai vus cet ours
ça après
quoiqu'il en à
un moment donné faut bien rentrer donc
je rentre à mon bivouac je dors la belle
étoile
je m'endors avec ça au dessus des yeux
et pour la première fois depuis
temps j'ai une trêve
donc je ne porte plus mon sac je fixe
deux étoiles des yeux et j'ai
l'impression de bascule en arrière comme
hypnotisé et je m'endors et ça fait du
bien de ne pas avoir peur de rêver bon
le lan 1
ac est remis en place malheureusement
c'est comme ça
je continue ma route je prends ma
voiture
je vais rouler toujours aussi stressé
et
roulé presque toute la journée
cette route elle s'enfonce dans la forêt
et puis de plus en plus je vois des
chemins à gauche à droite certains je
les prends deux ne les prend pas bref je
trace ma route à moi
arrivé au bout du chemin
j'ai trouvé quelque chose qui
je sais pas encore mais qui va me sauver
la vie
j'arrive et je vois deux jours
à 25 30 personnes peut être des adultes
les enfants des plus âgés il y en a qui
sont en train de jouer avec des jeux sur
la route il y en a qui sont en train de
de boire des bières y en a qui rigolent
bien qu'ils mangent
turia
personne qui vient vers moi
klein
il s'appelle team il vient vers moi et
10 mai
passé vieux pas forcément en fait je
cherche juste en coin pour la nuit ah
d'accord tu viens d'où je lui dis jury
français
avec mon accent il a compris je disais
je suis france et france puis non je
suis français
il se met à rire tape sur l'épaule et il
me dit tu veux une bière
c'est bien là
c'est bien
chose
et pu espérer
dix minutes après avoir accepté cette
bière
j'étais sur le bateau avec lui et sa
mère parce qu'ils avaient envie de me
faire découvrir cet endroit oui viennent
depuis 29 ans en famille en ami
me dis mais qu'est ce qui se passe
qu'est ce qui se passe mais c'est génial
et ils font faire ce tour du lac
garder deux jours avec eux ils vont me
donner ce à quoi j'ai droit c'est-à-dire
sorte d'amour altruiste ce à quoi j'ai
droit en tant qu'être humain pas plus
pas moins j'y ai droit au même titre que
vous tous
traitement en faveur et j'en veux pas
d'autres plaintes parce qu'il m'arrive
ça et j'en ai pas besoin
on aura des moments autour du feu
on aura des
des moments de rigolade j'entendrai des
histoires personnelles beaucoup plus
triste que la mienne
je
faire du
qui vont me faire faire des affaires
faire la bouée tractée et on fait
affaire du paddle ils vont faire faire
du ski nautique en faveur
oui parce que les américains qui part
dans le sauvage c'est pas comme nous
il ya toute une batterie de choses avec
tout ce qui m'arrive chaque seconde je
l'apprends et j'en reviens pas
le jour comme la nuit
et la première nuit je veux pas c'est
que je vais encore passer tout seul dans
mon duvet
je me mets dans mon duvet ce qui se
passe
soit que le sac je porte autour de la
poitrine même s'il est toujours là
tout tout le stress qui va l'intérieur
c'est parce que j'en ai payé et quelque
part je les pose et je sais pas où et je
m'en fous j'en ai pas besoin j'en ai
plus besoin en tout cas je n'en veux
plus
fois peut-être de ma vie en tout cas
sûrement depuis très longtemps je
m'endors avec le sourire
ces gens là ils m'ont acceptée
été
ils m'ont donné de leur quotidien pas
plus pas moins vous en scène ont fait un
cadeau
qui m'a sauvé la vie
jours
au moment de quitter donc
compliqué mais il faut bien faire
j'envoie un texto à la personne avec qui
voit là je
vis cette rupture je lui dis
maintenant je suis d'accord pour que tu
partes
alors pas besoin de la permission
mais moi j'avais besoin de le lire
j'avais besoin de formuler la chose de
dire ok maintenant je suis prêt
je rentre chez moi
et
je reprends un cours de y est il va se
et quelque chose c'est que je vais
repenser à toutes ses prises de vue je
vous ai parlé en 2018
ces choses dont je ne savais pas quoi
faire
et à ce moment là
à ce moment là ce qui va se passer c'est
que je vais savoir quoi en faire
chim
avec tout ça
c'est le deuil
raconter le deuil
quand tu es mon deuil
j'ai envie de raconter le deuil et à
travers
risma - à travers une sorte de chemin de
croix dans la montagne ce qui me paraît
être une bonne image parce qu'en
montagne on a des moments difficiles
comme des moments faciles des moments de
contemplation comme des moments de
difficulté que tout ça c'est très
difficile à anticiper
il s'appelle et puis je vois le bout
j'étais prêt
racontez ça
j'ai fait pour une autre raison c'est
qu'en fait je me suis rendu compte
qu'en faisant ce film et j'allais g -
clôture un chapitre me guérir quelque
part
j'avais la ferme volonté de faire ce
qu'on avait fait pour moi c'est à dire
donner
donner du temps du quotidien de la
considération mais encore une fois
juste ce qu'il fallait
j'ai voulu dire
gym
parce que j'ai voulu donner ce qu'on
m'avait donné je voulais faire à ma
manière j'ai voulu aider
c'est ce qui
traverse nous traverserons un deuil en
leur disant
qu'il ya du bon qu'il y a
prêts
parfois du temps
on n'est pas tous pareils qu'on n'est
pas tous égaux face à ça mais qu'il ya
forcément un après surtout quand on n'y
croit plus
voilà pourquoi j'ai fait ce film et
voilà pourquoi je suis là aujourd'hui
vous racontez ça pour vous dire
faut donner merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]